スイッグローバー開くと某からん
地域で活動する
この言葉を意識しながら
皆さん方は何か活動されていますか
私は
地球規模で考えながら地域で活動し
アートの力で発信しています
そんな大それたことと思われる方もおられるかもしれません
私にできることは
まず自分の古里の未来が
未来へと続くようにと願い活動すること
そしてあなたのふるさとも未来へと続くようにと願い
活動することです
私の故郷とあなたのふるさとはつながっている
そんな当たり前のようなことですが
ともに良くしていこうという思いを育てるには
学びが必要です
地球規模で考え
地域で活動するための学び
それが esb です
いいえ3とはエイディケーションを指してなブルー
ディベロプメントの薬
持続可能な開発のための教育と訳されています
この教育の特徴は
私たちの身のまわりにある様々な問題を
バラバラに取り組むのではなく
皆が力を合わせてつながりの中から解決していこうというものです
実はこの素晴らしい考え方を国連に提唱したのは日本
2005年から10年間の歩みの中で
世界で100以上もの地域がこの考え方を取り入れて発信しています
私が住んでいる北九州市もこの発信している地域の一つです
おととしの秋
アジア太平洋会議が開かれました
そして昨年秋は
岡山と名古屋で世界会議が開かれました
私はイエス d に取り組む
者の一人として岡山大会に参加しました
ここでは世界85カ国の人たちが
3なぁどうすれば地球はもっと良くなるのだろうかと
人間に語り合っていました
国と国を越えて
市民同士が当たり前のように語り合う
実はこの積み重ねこそが
地球の未来を作っていくのではないかと思いました
そんな私が
ふるさとづくりに水飴たきっかけは3つあります
一つは
私が子育てに一生懸命だった頃
自分の子供たち近所の子供たちにとってより良いふるさとをつくってあげたいと思い
ました
そこで私が一番最初に始めたことは子どもの遊び場づくりです
頭は一人で署名文を書いて近所のお母さん方に声をかけて
行政に働き掛け
5年がかりでようやくこの公園が出来ました
これはその公園開きのときの末尾の写真です
私はこのことによって市民参画の重要性を学びました
そして
親子の育ちあいの場としてこの公園が今も子どもたち大人たちをとても大切にされてい
ます
ところが
この公園ができてわずか3日後
北九州市やる
唯一の動物柄西鉄到津遊園の編が発表されました
この動物園は
私の父が10位として延長として長らく勤めていたえんです
森と動物たちを守りたい
その思いでまた再び署名文を書きました
そして
動物園の重要さえを伝えるために
作品展を開きました
またようやく存続になった後は
伊佐第二代がかかるといって
追い出されそうになったカバのために
私は f を作りました
そのようなさまざまな活動
やりました
ともに生きる
この作品はその時の私の森のすべてです
可愛いという人と気持ち悪いっていう人がいるんですけど
赤ちゃんとか米素晴らしいと思いません過去のハモリ方
私は
この体験によって
実はアートの力はすごいなっ
大きなものを動かすことができるんだと思いました
動物園の活動がようやく一段落した
時です
またまたなんですけど今度は私の実家の近くの床橋の海が
漁港道路建設のために女建てられることになりました
今度はこの浜を守りたいと立ち上がったのは
何と私の母親でした
そして仲間たち
仕方ないですね母親が立ち上がってしまったのだから応援しないといけません
そこそこで
まずですねこの浜なんですけれども
この浜は実は
英彦山修験道が
千年以上もお汐井取りに来ている浜田のです
けれども
この浜の価値をほとんどの人は知りませんでした
なぜならばそれは火木だったからです
そこで
私たちはこの故郷の宝を様々な方に読み解いていただきながら
故郷のたからの意味を伝えていきました
最初はこんなんだったんですよ
でなんとか端に決着したんですけれども
今
私は
福岡県と共同で
登録に京築故郷ミュージアムという故郷の宝を発信する事業
やっています
ところでみなさん
インタープリテーションという意味をご存知ですか
インタープリテーションとは直訳すると通訳するという意味なのですが
環境教育の世界では自然や文化を通訳するという意味です
つまりインタープリテーションすることによって故郷の
素晴らしさに気づき
その古里の素晴らしさの意味を築くことによって評価が生まれ
評価が生まれることによってようやく保全することができる
ということなのです
つまりインタープリテーションは初めの大切な大切な一歩生です
では
どうすれば
もっとより良く故郷の宝をたくさんの人に伝え
残すことができると皆さんがた思われますか
私は
子どもたちのためのうたプリてーしょんが一番重要だと思っています
子供の頃の経験は
その人の
根っことないっ
美希とない
はとなって大きなアイデンティティーの木を育てます
このアイデンティティーの危機こそ
故郷の宝を伝え
守ろうとする大きな力になると思うのです
そこで私はこの故郷の宝を伝えるために神楽は
蕪の紙芝居にしたり
鳥瞰図のマップを書いたり
また
故郷の生物多様性を伝えるために
布絵シアターカバンミュージアムというやり方を考えました
このカバンの中に入っているものは
布へ
そして
生き物たち
ok
そして
生き物たちのドラマです
ここは曽根干潟です
曽根干潟には
春になると
9さんの生き物たちがあ
動き出します
かにゃー
帰っ
とても豊かです
夏になるとお
干潟のの浜にカブトガニがやってきます
カブトガニは夫婦仲良し
2億年も昔からをやって命をつないでいるのです
ところでみなさんここでカブトガニは水です
カブトガニのオスとメスどちらがどっちかわかりますか
じゃあこのちっちゃい子これカブトガニの
お子だと思う人てあげてみてください
はい
じゃあこのちっちゃい方がメスだと思うぞ
みんな意外にわかってるんですかはっはー
はいそうなんですねカブトガニの雄は上
ミスはしたこうやってミスが卵でモスが政治をかけて
そして卵は孵化して海に泳いでいきます
さあカブトガニのつ切符は秋になると今度はたくさんの渡り鳥たちがやってきます
さあ渡り鳥さん来てください
はいっ
中国大陸からやってくる
ズグロカモメは自爪つ希少種です
えっ
さあ
どうぞお次
はいっ
はダイシャクシギ sunday はいっ
えっ
いいよ
パッ
はいえー
はいっ
さあそして冬の間この日形で過ごし
また春になると子育てのために
北へ帰っていきますごぞ狩りくださいはい
中国に帰ったズグロカモメよああ
卵を産んでそしてひなを育てます
そしてまた
秋にあると私たちの干潟に帰ってきてくれるのですありがとうござい
ました
こんな風にへ
渡り鳥に国境はありません
私たちはこの塗りあシアターを担いで
日中韓環境教育の交流のメンバーの一人として
中国や韓国でこの拭いシアターも上演してきました
そしてたくさんの友情を育んできました
生き物たちを守り支えようとするネットワークは
横へ
地球の架け橋になるのではないでしょうか
青い地球は
私の故郷であり
あなたのふるさとである
そして生き物たちの故郷です
今こそこの故郷のつながりを
大切にする学びが必要だと私は思います
今
私は
様々な救急現場を経て a
短大と大学で技術教育と環境教育を教えています
未来の先生
そして
book したたちだ
故郷の宝を
伝えることができるように
そして
私のライフワークであるこのアートで
故郷の宝を発信するという活動
これからも続けていきたいと思っています
ご静聴ありがとうございました